Prof: Now in the last
lecture we talked about how
China has had this very dense
population of very poor
peasants,
for a very long time,
and we started discussing some
of the possibilities for why
that would be.
We talked about the possibility
that China just had a higher
fertility rate and roughly that
was not true.
We found that that the
Europeans and the Chinese both
had methods of controlling their
population.
It doesn't mean the methods
were exactly equal,
but they were rather opposite.
The European method,
as you know was late marriage,
incomplete marriage that half
or so,
40% or 50% of people never got
married,
or were unmarried at any given
time,
a great deal of lack of
marriage and late marriage
meaning--
but once they got married they
did not seem to have any
limitation on their fertility
and so half the people going at
full tilt is sort of one
aliquot.
The Chinese situation,
10% to 25% of the girls were
done away with basically at
birth,
the rest all got married,
but within marriage they had a
very low rate of reproduction.
At the end, I don't think we'll
have time,
but if we do I'll show you some
of the evidence that this low
rate of reproduction was not a
conscious effort to control
fertility but was a result of
the culture.
I discussed--I gave you that
conclusion last time but I
didn't give you any data,
there's plenty of data for
that.
We're back to what the
difference is between China and
Europe, why are they so
different?
Student:  I just have a
question;
I'm wondering what extent do
you believe that cultural
programming was designed at some
early stage?
Prof: When you say
designed do you mean designed
consciously?
No, that I think the people had
no idea.
People obey various cultural
rules, cultural rules happen
randomly.
You can watch-- anthropologists
watch cultures and culture is a
very flexible thing and it
changes fairly frequently.
If that change works people
retain it and the whole culture
works.
If that doesn't work,
either people change it again
or the culture disappears.
Most cultures over time have
disappeared.
Cultural evolution seems to
follow pretty much the same
rules as biological evolution.
Almost random change--in
biology you have random changes
in the genome,
the cosmic ray hits you or you
smoke a cigarette,
or something like that,
and base pair changes or a
piece of chromosome jumps out
and goes back in,
inserts itself,
a lot of different things.
These are mostly bad changes
but very rarely there's a good
change.
If it's a good change
presumably that individual will
have more children and so
there's more copies of that
genome in the next generation
and so on.
You know the basic story of
evolution.
Culture evolution ca be the
same;
people change culture on the
basis of fads and who knows
what.
We've had a lot of evidence
that even the great reduction in
fertility that we've seen all
over the world,
has a lot of aspects of a fad.
That once a small group adopts
it everybody looks around and
likes the idea and fertility
drops like a stone,
way before and rather
independently of economic
changes,
and educational changes,
and urbanization changes and a
lot of the lectures have shown
that.
That something is adopted,
for maybe unclear reasons,
by a small group,
people like it,
it's like the kind of clothes
that you wear or something,
there's no rationality to it,
but if it works it gets
embedded in the culture.
No, I don't think there's any
evidence that any of these
practices were put into place
for the purpose that we now
impute to them,
but they're practices that
worked for that culture within
the rest of their ecological and
cultural context,
and so it persisted.
That's a very important--it's a
good question,
it's a very important way of
thinking about culture.
That it evolves very much in
the same way that biological
things evolve,
and it's a decent introduction
to what I want to say today.
One of the strong aspects of
culture is family.
In Chinese cultures,
as in many others,
it's really the very center of
Chinese culture;
the family and their
responsibilities to each other.
We talked, and I'll go back
over it a little bit,
about how loosely bound the
families in Europe were.
I'll refer to this later.
In China, families are much
more tightly bound.
It's a much more functional
unit.
This binding was ordered by
Confucian doctrine for a long
time in China.
That is, women had to give
absolute deference to men;
children had to give absolute
deference to parents and elders,
for instance.
The relationship between
parents and children are
extremely important and in China
children did not leave the home.
In Europe, remember I described
to you that at age seven,
Charles Dickens goes out and
works and people are sent out to
do service in different places
or would be apprentices.
Of course everything happened
in China, but the most usual
thing was that the children were
kept at home and worked on the
family land.
The parents chose a spouse for
the child,
again in Europe,
people went out and had what
they called morganatic
marriages,
marriages presumably for love,
but the parents were not
involved in the marriage.
In China, after marriage,
the son remained living in his
parent's compound and the
daughter-in-law moved in with
them;
very, very standard kind of
situation.
There was no separate economic
unit for the married children.
As long as the father lived he
controlled the assets of all the
family,
the children did not have
independent stuff and money that
they owned,
it was all under the control of
the father,
and in old age it was the
children and not the community
who were responsible for support
of the parents.
That was part of the
tit-for-tat;
again in the culture this is
very closely arranged.
The parents have
responsibilities toward the
children;
the children have
responsibilities toward the
parents.
The parents support the
children when they're young,
provide land for them,
when they inherit the land,
but in return the children must
support the parents in old age.
Living in the family of your
parents is a very conservative
effect because the older
generation gets to dictate the
customs and mores and the
behavior of the younger
generation,
and older generations are by
definition conservative because
they were brought up in an older
version of things,
and there may be modern things
going on but they don't
generally accept them.
With respect to fertility,
with respect to son preference,
a boy who may be 17 marries a
girl who may be 13,
14,15--and the boy is under the
thumb of his mother and the girl
moves into the house and she's
only 13 and she's under the
thumb of everybody,
and the mother insists that she
get pregnant right away and have
a boy.
She describes it as:
'for my son's benefit.'
The cultural thing is,
she's doing it so that my son
will pass on the family name.
It's good for my son.
But, the son probably doesn't
want it as times modernize.
He wants to enjoy his life and
enjoy his wife and so forth,
but they have little power,
the son and the daughter-in-law
have little power.
It's the grandparents that have
the cultural power in the family
so it's a very conservative
factor in cultures and
especially in matters of
reproduction.
In return, as I mentioned,
for children giving up autonomy
which they give up,
the children are very much
under control of their parents,
and for living in this absolute
deference.
Fathers, in a lot of China,
at different times in history
had the right to kill a child if
the child was disobedient.
That was not against the law.
In return for this,
they had to support the
children of all ages,
find spouses,
and ensure resources for the
next generation and the essence,
in a sense, is really the only
resource that peasants generally
have is some land,
that meant giving the children
land for the next generation.
In England especially,
and in a lot of the rest of
Europe,
they practiced primogeniture,
that only the oldest son got
the land,
and so the holdings,
whatever amount of land the
parents had was kept together.
The Chinese did not practice
primogeniture.
We're talking about a lot of
places over a long time so I'm
sure there were some places
where it happened,
but in general,
they did not practice
primogeniture.
On the death of the father,
the family land would be
divided up among however many
sons that there were.
This had the good benefit that
no one was forced,
and one of the cultural reasons
for it,
that with land you could start
a family,
you could have children,
you could have sons,
so no one would be forced into
the situation which was
unbearable in traditional
Chinese culture of not having a
son.
You had to have son,
in order to have a son you had
to have a wife.
In order to have a wife you had
to have means of supporting her
a little bit,
so the family had to give you
land.
This factor,
the lack of--the division of
family land in China had
tremendous impact on the whole
economic situation of China;
of course, as population grew,
that guaranteed that the plots
of land would get smaller and
smaller, and smaller right down
to the subsistence level.
And the Chinese were very well
aware of this.
A common Chinese saying,
which summarized this
phenomenon says,
"fortunes seldom continue
considerable in the same family
beyond the third
generation."
If you're Chinese and say that,
we have similar sayings in the
western world,
but they're very different
meanings.
In China what it means,
if you have a fortune,
if you're rich,
you'll be able to keep more of
your children alive including
the sons.
If you have more sons you have
to divide your land into more
small pieces and you go right
back to the poverty level.
When we say things like that in
the West, it means the first
generation works very hard,
is honorable in a sense,
makes money.
The second generation have seen
their parents work,
retains some of that work
ethic, but the children,
the grandchildren grow up rich
and they're rotters and they
don't work very hard.
The same cultural impression
works in both cultures that
riches don't last very long in
generations,
but one is due to the scarcity
of the division of land and one
is due to the personality of the
individual.
Malthus knew about this saying,
the saying is so popular in
China,
Malthus knew about this saying
and wrote about it 200 years ago
and it's still common--
that I read it as a Chinese
saying in The New York Times
a few years ago.
Again, this is in contrast to
the European situation where
children left home early to work
in a succession of other
households.
They chose their own spouses,
very interestingly,
as evidence of this kind of
dissolution that in most of the
world we have these tight
families when someone gets
married there's some record of
it,
there's some registry,
a personal family record kept
as a family treasure or some
governmental or village,
or religious record,
and in all these countries with
tight marriages there's a long
list of relatives that have
witnessed the weddings and say
yes this is true.
Not in England,
the list--it's--the two people
go to church,
or a priest,
or a minister marries them and
that's it.
The family can be involved but
need to have nothing to do with
it and legally doesn't have
anything to do with it.
After marriage,
unless they are the
primogeniture son that is
inheriting the father's
household,
they go and set up their own
household somewhere else and
live separately.
As soon as they get married
they're economically independent
of their parents.
In one data set,
in 75% of cases in northwest
Europe,
children didn't even live in
the same village where their
parents lived,
so it wasn't like they were
really close but they moved
away.
Now again, in cultures all
these--a lot of things have to
fit together so the system of
independence,
the European system,
could only occur if some
provision is made for support of
the elderly.
In China the young--the
children have the responsibility
to take care of the elderly and
this has to happen,
all elderly need to be taken
care of,
and the culture would never
evolve successfully if there
wasn't some way of European
oldsters getting some sort of
support.
Interestingly,
in Europe it was not the
children who were responsible
for support of the elderly,
but the community had that
responsibility.
From 1598, Parliament--and
that's a long time ago 1598,
Parliament required overseers
of the poor to be appointed
every year in every parish in
the country;
every parish was responsible
for its own poor,
which was mostly elderly.
They not only had the duty to
support anybody that came and
asked for it who was indeed
poor, they had to go out and
identify the poor.
They had to--the poor that were
too helpless,
or too ignorant,
or didn't know,
they had the responsibility to
go out and identify the poor.
We have a lot of argumentation
in America,
especially about our current
welfare state,
how much effort should the
welfare agencies do to pull in
clients for their services,
to advertise their services.
Well, 1598 England faced of
course the same issue and the
Parliament then decided that no,
the responsibility of the
community was to go out and
identify and find people who
needed help.
These overseers were empowered
to levy taxes sufficient to pay
for this.
The law was very clear that the
primary responsibility for
providing relief lay with the
parish;
that was what happened.
There was no direct obligation
recognized between the child and
the parent.
A parent could not go and sue
his children for support.
There was a back door,
a little loophole that once the
parish discharged its
responsibility in supporting the
poor,
than the parish could go and
sue the child to reimburse the
parish for its expenses,
so it wasn't totally that the
children got off the hook.
That was when the children
lived in a different village and
this was all very localized,
it was a very hard thing to
enforce,
and basically it was the
community that had this
responsibility.
Colonial America picked up that
same pattern,
and there are really quite
horrible stories of pregnant
women,
who either got pregnant out of
wedlock or whose husband had
died,
or had gone off to a war or
something,
sort of being chased from
village to village while they
were pregnant and ready to give
birth because the village knew
that if that child was born in
that village they would ever
after have to do poor relief for
the mother and the child.
There's some really unpleasant
stories from Colonial America.
Well so you have two different
patterns,
a Chinese, and of course it's
not limited to China,
where the children are under
the thumb of the grandparents,
especially the grandmother in
reproductive matters and so
behavior is not terribly
flexible.
It's whatever the older
generation believed.
Whereas in Europe,
children go out and form their
own households and they can
respond more easily to changes
in cultural norms.
The younger boys,
it's quite interesting,
while one of the results of
primogeniture is that you keep
the plots together so that,
in the peasantry,
you don't have this enormous
class of terribly poor peasants,
the peasants retain a
reasonable amount of land.
But all the rest of the sons go
off to the cities and they get
forced off the land.
Demographically they usually
don't require the resources to
get married because in the
cities it's very hard to
accumulate the resources.
They never get married,
they never have children,
as I mentioned before the death
rates in the cities were so
incredibly high that about every
generation about a third of the
city people died and had to be
replaced by new immigrants from
the countryside.
Still, there was quite a large
population of unemployed or
barely employed people in the
cities.
What did they do?
They joined armies,
that's one of the big
employers--especially of men,
big armies--require manpower.
Some historians believe that
the aggressiveness of Europe,
all the constant wars that
Europe was in during this period
and the colonial expansion,
were due to all these young men
in the army and they had to do
something with them.
Or reverse, they were available;
all these young men were
available for the army and so
they were employed to do
whatever the rulers believed
they should do.
They also tried to make a
living in the city and did a lot
of apprenticeship,
and they would start a small
trade,
or some hand manufacturing
operation,
and again some historians
believe that this excess of
males in the city trying to cope
on their own--
formed one of the basis for the
industrial revolution.
The two systems were
really--the European and Chinese
were sort of diametrically
opposite and the Chinese system
was in a sense much kinder
because no one would--
in Europe children were sort of
basically sacrificed,
goodbye, have a good time in
life, we'll see you.
Whereas, in China,
they were kept at home in the
security of the family and its
land,
which is both emotionally more
secure and economically more
secure,
but very poor.
It looks like this very
practice, which is the center of
Chinese culture,
the tightness of the family,
with respect for elders,
lack of adolescent rebellion,
etc.,
all the good characteristic
things that go along with that,
may also be one of the reasons
why China suffered the
Malthusian misery situation for
so long.
The land parcels on which
people tried to survive were
just so tiny that they were up
against an absolute limit.
All right, we can see in the
statistics, the result of this
keeping people on the land.
China, basically as observed by
Chinese and by everyone else,
became what was called a vast
sea of impoverished rural
peasants.
As late as 1900,94% of Chinese
lived in villages,
meaning they were agricultural.
In contrast,
in England 100 years earlier in
1800, the agricultural
population was down to 37%.
So, China was way more than 100
years behind England,
at least in urbanizing and
industrializing and so forth.
Without enough land,
nonetheless,
when the plots got so small
that people really could not
survive on them,
of course even in China they
had to leave the land,
and you got a class of landless
laborers,
as there really was everywhere.
But the conditions which they
left in Europe--
The poverty on the farms was so
much worse than,
say in Europe,
that when they moved to the
cities it was even a step
further down.
This is really disastrous.
In the 1930s both Americans and
Mao,
Mao did some of his earliest
scholarly work investigating
conditions of the rural poor in
China,
and so there's a fair amount of
data that in the 1930s wages
that to be paid for a laborer,
what you paid a man to work for
a day,
was the same as it cost you to
provide fodder for a donkey.
The cost per day of a donkey
and a human were the same,
it was such absolute misery.
Which did people prefer to hire?
Buy a donkey or hire a human?
Same cost per day--what?
Student:  Depends on
what you have to do.
Prof: Okay,
all the things that donkeys or
humans can do,
but donkeys especially,
what can a donkey do?
It carries things.
It turns out that they
preferred to hire the human.
Why?
Because if you have a donkey,
you have to feed him every day,
even when the donkey is not
working.
If you have a human,
you pay him for that day,
essentially subsistence wages,
just enough food to keep going
which is more or less the same
as the donkey.
And when you don't need them,
when the harvest is gone,
or you don't have anything to
carry, bye.
That's what you see in the
Chinese cities of all this time
that there was very little
mechanized transport,
everything was carried by
rickshaw;
rickshaw is a seat but human
laborers were carrying all the
goods around the cities and
between cities.
On the farms also,
labor was so cheap and there
were so many humans per land,
that there was no economic
incentive to get animals to do
your heavy labor.
So, there was an absence of
draft animals in China,
an amazing difference between
Europe and China is the absence
of draft animals.
It's very interesting,
draft animals not only provide
you pulling labor,
but they provide manure,
and Europe had plenty of manure
from all the--
they had a lot of animals.
The Chinese then had to go to
human manure.
The whole industry of spreading
the human manure,
night soil as they call it,
on the fields is due to a lack
of draft animals.
This continued as late as the
1970s, some parts of China were
still too poor to have farm
animals.
You didn't get mechanized
farming, you didn't get any of
the--
labor was so cheap they didn't
get any of the mechanization of
either motorized transport in
cities or agricultural machinery
in the countryside.
This kind of--people coming
down to a very,
very--because the land got so
crowded,
people coming down to a very,
very poor state of existence
was really a great weakness of
China.
While, at the top,
the Emperor and the court were
fabulously wealthy,
that was based on the backs of
a mass of really,
really poor peasants.
When Europe developed good
shipping and modern arms--
was starting to develop modern
armaments they were able to
thrust their power all the way
from Europe around most of the
world.
It's not very easy to get by
sailing ship from Europe to
China,
but by the early 1800s Europe
could project enough military
power into China to defeat the
Chinese armies.
As I mentioned last time,
the British were,
by that time,
having a terrible trade deficit
with China.
The British were addicted to
tea, and they were losing all
their money and the tea
addiction would have choked--
the ledgers are very clear
how--England was just basically
losing all its money and if they
didn't restore the balance of
trade,
Europe would be bankrupt and
that would have cut off the
industrial revolution.
The money that could have
fueled the industrial revolution
was in fact going to China to
feed a caffeine addiction.
It was really a massive,
massive effect and so the
British started importing opium
into China,
from India, in an attempt to
reverse the balance of trade,
which it did.
I mentioned this,
the Chinese put down their foot
and said 'no you can't addict my
people,' the British cried free
trade,
invaded China in the first and
the second opium war.
By about 1840 it was clear that
China was a paper tiger
militarily.
Though they really had a vast
number of people in a very
strong autocratic state,
they could not respond to
Western military power.
Once kicked out--for a short
interim there,
before the opium war,
the Chinese were able to kick
the opium smugglers out.
Where did they go?
To a little rocky island off
the coast of South China,
and now that's called Hong
Kong.
It started as a smuggler's den,
and basically the big Jardine
Matheson,
all the big British fortunes
that stemmed from the China
trade were really opium trade,
drug trade.
The British started controlling
parts of China,
then the Germans moved in,
the French moved in,
and the Americans when--in the
periods when China's government
had some power were very happy
to intermediate in the drug
trade,
and help avoid certain
restrictions on the Brits and so
forth.
Then the Japanese got
modernized in the early 1900s
and they invaded China,
and the end result of this,
is that from the first opium
war for 115 years China was
basically at the mercy of the
European imperial powers and the
Japanese newly imperial state.
The final chapter on that,
of course,
is World War II where the
Japanese invaded and were
incredibly brutal to the
Chinese,
and I read you sometime back,
a story about the Rape of
Nanking,
and then after that there was
the battle between the
communists and the nationalists,
won by the communists;
a very, very vicious civil war.
Basically China was devastated
by this 115 years of dissolution
of the government and being
taken advantage of by foreign
powers.
The scarcity of land,
just as a sort of footnote to
that history,
the scarcity of land remains a
major problem for China.
Especially the dry and hilly
land, you may remember last time
I told you that as American
foods came in and farming
increased,
that people learned that they
could grow food on hilly land
and dry land,
and so the population expanded
into this marginal land.
February, the end of February
this year,
just a month ago,
there was a story in The
Times. China's now going
through the worst drought in
half a century,
which also means that they go
through this every half century,
so it's not really an
incredibly unusual thing.
In the wheat band,
a farmer's land is 1/3 of an
acre,
and remember I told you the
average plot farm size was only
1/10th of an acre,
so this guy is rich.
He's got 1/3 of an acre,
three times as much.
Why does he have so much?
Because it's carved out of a
rocky hillside in a dry region.
You can't survive on a 1/10th
of an acre there,
you need 3/10ths of an acre.
The aquifers have been so
depleted that,
in some farming regions,
wells have to go down a half
mile before striking water;
all the water that's less
further down has already been
used up.
They're going through this
drought.
These people,
in good times,
live on a 1/3 of an acre.
On a hilly, rocky,
dry hillside,
you're not going to make a lot.
And now, with the economic
collapse in the world,
there's millions of migrant
workers coming back onto the
farms--
the countryside and they're
going to have to now,
somehow, be supported on this
very,
very poor agriculture.
Finally, after the Korean War,
I may have forgotten to mention
the Korean War,
where the--some elements of the
United States said they were
going to invade China.
This was the time when they
were threatening to bomb China
back to the Stone Age.
Do you know that expression?
It was Senator William Knoland
from California who was the main
advocate of bombing China back
to the Stone Age.
The U.S.
did not invade China and China
fought them in North Korea;
very, very nasty,
bloody situation.
They finally got this peace.
The data seems to show that in
1952,
which is at the end of the
Korean War,
Chinese had a significantly
lower per capita income than
they had at the end of the Sung
Dynasty in the thirteenth
century.
That there had been 700 years
with--600 or 700 years with no
progress--real progress for the
people.
It was a real Malthusian
situation where the population
had grown up tremendously,
production had increased
tremendously,
but the two equaled out and no
net progress.
There's the new communist
government which was very
powerful and not hesitant about
using its power and being very
autocratic.
Right away they did a number of
very good things,
they invested very heavily in
public health,
and introduced the very basic
measures of hygiene,
disease control and pest
control.
It's a big thing.
Loudspeakers--this period
loudspeakers everywhere in China
were blaring to the people,
you didn't have any time to
think because there were
loudspeakers everywhere at you.
"Honorable elders please
do not spit on the ground."
Any of--you Chinese have heard
this or stories of this?
You have.
There was a big campaign to
swat flies;
the flies were spreading
disease from the feces which was
not in--not flushed away in
toilets.
So flies would step into the
feces and then step onto you.
So the same thing,
swat a fly and they killed
zillions of flies.
The flies eventually did get
controlled in China and whether
it was due to the swat--a-fly
campaign or not,
I don't know.
Due to these things,
by 1957, which,
remember, we have a devastated
country where the government
takes control in 1949,
in eight years the death rate
went to half what it had been.
That's an amazing,
amazing achievement.
When you cut the death rate in
half, what happens?
Population explosion;
so China had its most extreme
population explosion after the
communists came to power.
Now these are not ignorant
people.
Were they worried about the
population explosion?
The answer is: absolutely not.
Marxist theory is very
pronatalist.
Marx hated Malthus,
there's a long literature of
communist, socialist invective
against Malthus,
and they're really opposite
poles.
Now it's sort of the right wing
and the extreme left thing that
it opposes Malthus,
and liberals and moderates are
more predisposed toward him.
At any rate,
the Marxist theory
is--basically says this.
Look, in the capitalist
economy, the capitalist take
workers,
they employ them in factories,
and they make a surplus,
so the capitalist lives very
well on the surplus.
The socialist economy can do
just as well.
It can employ the workers,
and they can make a surplus
over them,
but instead of having big fat
mansions and cigars,
the socialist government will
reinvest the money for the good
of the people,
so the more people the merrier.
Marx--original Marxist doctrine
was very,
very clear that since the
capitalist can exploit labor,
so can the state and that will
move down to the benefit of the
people.
The way this was translated
from Marx into China,
they call Malthusian's theory
something like 'ren kou lun,
which means 'man mouth theory,'
which means that every man is
born with a mouth,
i.e., he's a consumer and that
splits up the pie.
The Marxist translate their
theory as 'man hand theory,'
that a man is born not only with
a mouth to consume but a hand to
do work,
and the question is if
the--that the socialist state
can employ the hands to produce
more than the mouth require,
so they didn't buy,
they were very in favor of high
population.
In 1949, Mao,
becoming in charge of a very
devastated country says,
"Revolution plus
production will enable China to
feed and employ the large and
growing population."
No worry; until they got some
facts.
In 1953 the country was stable
enough that they took their
first national census.
At that time,
they thought they had something
like 426 million people and that
the number had not been growing
in the century because of all
the civil and foreign wars,
and natural calamities in China.
It was a disaster,
so they thought,
well, population can't grow
under those situations.
Then they took a census and
they counted 600 million people,
which was 50% more,
a third larger than they had
expected that were there.
The error, what they expected
to find and what they did find,
was equal to the whole U.S.
population at that time,
so it was a big shock.
They finally responded
rationally, and immediately
China passed the contraceptives
and induced abortion act,
legalizing the importation and
sale of contraceptives and
legalizing sterilization and
abortion.
There was one small problem,
they didn't have any
contraceptives,
they didn't have the
manufacturing facilities,
so they legalized the
importation of them and
imported--
But, the Chinese had no foreign
currency at that time,
it was way, way before any kind
of economic progress,
and so they just didn't have it.
The cities got--there was
always some money in the cities,
so the cities got some of the
foreign contraceptives and--
but in the countryside where
the vast,
vast majority of the people
lived at the time and basically
had no access,
and if they did have access
they wouldn't have been able to
afford them,
so the government policy was
basically meaningless.
What was the government to do?
In 1956 they realized that just
proclaiming something doesn't
help, so they said,
well let's use traditional
medicine.
They asked all the traditional
Chinese doctors what to do.
You must have traditional ways
of contraception,
of keeping women from having
children.
One of these became very well
popularized--popularized in the
press.
On the third day following her
period,
a woman should ingest 14 live
tadpoles,
than ten the next day,
and then the woman would be
assured sterility for five
years.
If the woman did this twice,
then traditional medicine said
that the woman would be
permanently sterile.
It's not totally clear whether
this was the policy that the
government was really behind.
This was the procedure that the
government was doing,
but the press picked up and it
was a very big press thing in
China,
and it was very much followed
by the people.
The very small ecological
movement in China really got
worried that in China--that
frogs would go extinct because
people are eating all the
tadpoles.
Finally the Chinese Academy of
Science took it up,
got the statistics,
did some experiments,
I don't know exactly what they
did but they said,
no this doesn't work.
Go back to drawing board,
what are we going to do.
So, the next round 1957/1958
was to use acupuncture as a
contraceptive.
Remember acupuncture in China
has never been used for the
kinds of things that it is used
for here,
and there's no evidence of any
effect from this for anything
except the spread of hepatitis
because the needles weren't
sterilized.
You can see that throughout
Asia.
I may have mentioned this in a
previous lecture,
so they said OK let's try it
for contraception,
and of course that didn't work
any better whatsoever.
Politically,
the government,
again it was a very new thing
and the traditional Marxists
were still opposed to family
planning that other,
more modern aspects of the
government were in favor of,
so the government was uncertain
and divided on this.
But, in 1956 the Premier,
Zhou En-lai,
at the time a very powerful
guy, urged limitations on
childbirth and he was supported
by influential economists who
were very much influenced by
Western ideas from Malthus
onward,
Western ideas on population.
The very next year--so in 1956
was when they started all this,
really trying to push birth
control,
the very next year there was
one of the Chinese purges.
In 1957 they had the
campaign--what they called the
anti-rightist campaign --
and people who were too
influenced by Western ideas,
and Western economic ideas,
remember Malthus was considered
the father of Western economics,
were purged and with them went
the family planning campaign.
In the end, the early back and
forthing on family planning came
to no effect;
there were no methods,
no trained family planning
personnel, and no facilities in
rural areas, and no tradition of
anything.
In 1958, the Party started
organizing communes,
and you probably know a fair
amount about them.
These were giant agricultural
enterprises with something like
5,000 families in a single
commune.
Commune meaning all the
production from all the farmland
owned by 5,000 families was
pooled, and they produced
together and they consumed
together.
That particular summer,
for climatic reasons,
the harvest turned out to be
excellent,
and, as the data came in,
the leaders of communist China
at the time decided that the
communes were the answer.
"Look at how well we've
done under this commune
system."
And the cadres,
the lower down cadres who were
going to be rewarded or punished
depending on their production,
they of course inflated figures
wildly and they claimed that
rural production had doubled,
had increased tenfold,
or even scores of times.
It was really--there was indeed
a good harvest,
but then that got inflated
enormously due to the--shall we
say, the weak political process.
In 1958 after a couple of years
of trying this--
officially pushing family
planning but without any real
policy that worked,
and with getting rid of the
rightists who were in favor of
it,
in 1958 they reversed again.
They went away from family
planning and they said the
central--
the communist party's central
committee said in 1958 that the
communes were so successful that
'China no longer had to worry
about overpopulation'.
To the contrary,
the forthcoming problem would
be "not so much
overpopulation as the shortage
of manpower."
Basically what they got carried
away with,
Jonathan Spence,
in his history of China,
talks about this,
and says, "the vision of
utopia was altogether
intoxicating".
Whenever your view of the world
gets out of kilter with the
reality,
disaster is right behind and
the disaster is indeed not far
behind and that was the Great
Leap Forward.
The context of the Great Leap
Forward is that the U.S.,
in particular,
had threatened China and been
threatening China with nuclear,
basically annihilation,
and Mao had answered with this:
'I have so many people if you
kill a couple of hundred million
who cares';
very brutal response and
counter response.
The answer, Mao and everybody
in China knew,
was to industrialize as fast as
they possibly can to catch up to
America in military might.
He decided that China was not
industrializing fast enough and
had to catch up to the Western
level right away.
He told--he ordered--the orders
went out from the central
bureaucracy to put all of their
efforts into industrialization.
Forget about farming,
we have plenty of food,
the communes are producing
plenty of food,
we don't have to worry about
that.
In fact, in your backyard,
put iron smelters in,
build little furnaces and smelt
your iron in your backyard.
People didn't have any iron
ore, so what they did,
they took their pots and pans,
put them into a smelter,
then they took their farm
implements and put them into the
smelter.
If you're from China,
do you remember your parents or
somebody talking about these
days?
Again you do;
we don't have too many
native-borns here,
but it was very,
very big, the backyard iron and
it resulted in two things.
One, when you destroy
agricultural implements your
agriculture really does go to
hell and the iron that you can
smelt in the backyard is not
very good iron,
so it's not very--actually very
useful.
The side result is that
agriculture production crashed,
absolutely crashed.
At the same time,
as part of the communes,
the communal kitchens were
established where everyone could
eat together.
The purpose of--the original
purpose was twofold.
One they wanted--Chinese work
very hard to modernize the
country,
to build up the country,
and each family going home for
lunch and dinner is a huge
amount of labor involved in
preparing meals,
especially with a fairly
primitive food cooking and
gathering,
preparing technology.
If you have a staff dedicated
for food and you make food for
thousands of people,
it can be done very efficiently
in terms of time,
it's economically a very
efficient sort of thing.
It also was a pro-feminist
measure that who had to do the
work at home was the women.
The women were working in the
fields, then the men could come
home and relax,
but the women had to then take
care of the children and the
food.
It was both an economic
rationalization measure and it
was a pro-feminist measure.
The result was that consumption
soared.
Traditionally,
like all poor people around the
world, the Chinese were very
abstemious, every grain of rice
counts.
In a poor family,
if there's food available,
you eat just exactly what you
need to stay alive,
and you store away the rest for
the future,
because the future is always
very uncertain.
When you have a communal
kitchen, it doesn't do any good
to not eat your fill because,
if you don't eat your fill,
someone else will.
There's no individual
accounting, no individual
responsibility,
so everyone ate a lot and
consumption soared at just the
time that production is going
down.
The concatenation of those two
things was the disaster.
As the disaster unfolded,
China was sufficiently
authoritarian at the time that
the cadres had to pass up good
news to the higher levels,
so news of the disaster that
was unfolding before the local
people's eyes was not passed up
to higher levels.
Apparently the higher levels
really believed that the--that
agriculture was keeping up with
all this consumption.
The higher levels only
received, and especially Mao,
received only glowing reports
of production--agricultural
production in the countryside.
What happened was the great
famine of the great leap
forward.
Several hundred million people
became undernourished during
this period, and then people
starved;
source of undernourishment and
then people starved.
Massive famines from 1959 to
1961;
we don't know how many people
died in these famines.
The estimates are 20,30,
40,50 million people dying of
starvation, but what it was we
don't know.
This is--let me show you the
other one first.
This is an old--this is world
population and you can go back
further, except for the
black--there's no other--you see
that blip there?
That's the Great Leap Forward
in China as part of world
population.
There is--if you carry world
population back further you
don't see any blip like that
except the Black Death.
All the other disasters are not
comparable to this.
This shows sort of a Western
estimate going from something
like loss of 30 or 40 million
people.
The official Chinese statistics
show the death rate going from
10 million to 25 million,
and you have to look at the
area because there's one,
two, three years of it so
they're estimating more like
maybe 25 million deaths,
that's the official Chinese
statistics.
Of course in that extreme
poverty, the birthrate just
crashes and then recovers when
food becomes available again.
So the moral of the story is
that the Chinese seem to
have--in the early stages of the
commune system,
the Chinese seem to have
eradicated famine.
They had had 115 years of
miserable history,
the Communists come in,
things get better very quickly,
very fast.
They decide they have the
answer, they decide they don't
have to pay attention to basic
realities like population and so
they get a very unreal view of
reality.
Meanwhile, the country is
actually still walking on the
edge of disaster,
before they were under the edge
and falling off to disaster
before the revolution,
after the revolution they were
still on the edge,
but that wasn't realized.
So it was stupidity,
a political mistake pushes them
over the edge and you have this
huge amount of death.
You should be aware that when
people talk about environmental
limits what happens with
population and the world,
that there are all kinds of
physical limits to the number of
people.
The most delicate thing that
humans make are their social and
political arrangements.
When things get very tight it's
almost always not an underlying
fundamental resource problem or
something,
it's peoples political response
to it,
their interpersonal response to
it that goes out of whack and
they start making massive
mistakes like this and then the
world falls apart.
It's the political and social
arrangements that people make
with each other that are the
most delicate and population
stress will usually have its
disaster effects through--
acting through the political
and social arrangements.
Then the Chinese did not have
any rest after this.
From the Great Leap Forward to
the 1960s -- in the early 1960s
got transformed into the
Cultural Revolution of the
mid-60s and there was more
chaos.
After the great famine the
government learned its lesson
and again tried to institute
birth control flip flop,
flip flop, and again the method
was largely propaganda.
The kind of propaganda this
time was aimed a lot at men and
the kind of things that the
Chinese press were touting were
men before the age of 25--
remember again it's a
restriction on the young men
from sex--
were described as if you have
sex "excessive dissipation
of bodily fluids,
sexual neurasthenia,
low spirits,
headaches,
discomfort all over the body,
emaciation,
dizziness, tension,
memory loss,
premature old age,
mental and physical pain,
and impotence."
Now I've heard this from
students as their problems but
they usually now attribute to
lack of sex,
but the Chinese at that time
were attributing it to sex,
so you take your chances.
Nevertheless,
the situation in the cities was
such that the conditions,
the housing scarcity,
the poverty were such that
people,
indeed in the cities,
did reduce their fertility and
by 19--
somewhere in 1964 or 1966
window, the urban fertility
dropped to a low of three births
per woman.
By 1974, urban non-agricultural
women,
their fertility was reduced to
replacement level,
so, rather rapidly,
urban fertility came down and
it's continued to come down,
and in 1980 it was 1.1;
very low urban fertility.
During the Cultural Revolution
it had remained very high
because it was chaos and nobody
was watching the store.
In 1970 it was 6.4 among rural
women,
6.4 children which is basically
the traditional number from way,
way back and so there was
basically no conscious fertility
control among the rural women.
By 1969 the population passed
800 million and in 1970,
21% of births,
one out of five were first
births,
17% almost the same were second
but 62% were third or higher
order births in 1970,
so almost everyone was having
three or more children.
When political stability was
finally restored after the
disruption of the Great Leap
Forward and the Cultural
Revolution,
the government really
introduced a serious,
vigorous family planning
program.
Starting in 1971 they
introduced the Wan,
Xhi Shao;
later, longer, fewer.
What they proposed was later
marriage, longer birth
intervals, leading to fewer
children overall.
This was propagandized very
heavily but this is debatable,
but there was generally
considered to be not an awful
lot of coercion involved.
It was more or less a voluntary
campaign.
I want to show you one graph if
I can--okay here's a graph of
the total fertility rate in
China and I have taken out the
years.
I'll show you the years in a
minute.
When do you think--so you had
the Wan,
Xi, Shao, the voluntary policy,
and then that lasted for about
ten years and then you had the
one-child policy which was,
at least in the beginning,
not very voluntary and you've
heard about that?
Where do you think the
one-child policy starts?
Where in this graph?
To show you the effectiveness
of political programs.
No idea.
Well it was--do you think the
one child policy was effective?
Student:  Yes.
Prof: Yes,
therefore you put it--
Student:  I don't know
where I'd put it.
Prof: Make a guess.
I know you don't have--right
about there maybe.
That's the Great Leap Forward
decline.
The one-child policy starts
here, levels off,
this decline,
taking about ten years was
during the Wan Xi Shao period
during the more or less
voluntary period.
That the big drop in Chinese
fertility happens here and then
they introduce the one-child
policy actually right about
here,
well I'll just show you the
actual dates.
Here's 1980,
the one child policy is
introduced here,
and immediately the fertility
rises and then stabilizes and
I'll show you later eventually
it does slow down for all kinds
of reasons.
Let me go back,
the important thing to know is
that it was the 19--
that the drop is 1970 to 1980,
in this ten years,
the ten years before the
one-child policy,
is when Chinese fertility
really took this enormous drop.
What happened was until the
1970s, as I've described,
there were really no family
planning services in the vast
rural areas and only limited
facilities in a few of the large
cities.
Starting in the 1970s,
as part of this policy,
contraceptives were made
available;
a huge amount of propaganda was
made to counteract any taboos.
Peasant people have a lot of
taboos, and established late
marriage and the small family as
the desirable norm.
This drop--we've seen drops
something like this fast since
then, but this drop was,
at the time,
just incredible to foreign
observers.
That, in one decade,
to go down from six to half
your--
more than half your fertility
this is about 2.5 in one decade,
in a place so vast and so
traditional as China was at that
time,
just unbelievable.
I mean it turned out to be true;
the Chinese statistics were
indeed quite good on this.
It shows what a family planning
program, in this case,
introduced with the full effort
of the government,
can really accomplish.
Scholars said it's the most
extraordinary reduction in
fertility in a large population
ever recorded in human history.
In 1979 the results of the
second national census were
released and it was clear that
the population was approaching
one billion people.
Now to us nowadays,
we're used to hearing China as
having more than a billion
people,
but back then,
the idea of a single country
having a billion people was
absolutely mind boggling,
and remember 1979 was way
before the Chinese economic
miracle,
so these were a billion very
poor people that were going to
be on earth.
As the Chinese saw it,
very explicitly saw it,
the population they had--they
had had very good economic
gains,
nothing like the boom that
happened later,
but they really had made good
progress but they perceived that
population growth had eaten up
all of their gains.
For instance,
grain production increased an
annual rate of 2.3% between 1957
and 1978,
the year before the census,
but per capita consumption
which had started extremely low
increased only 0.2% during this
time,
so it's a very small--huge
increase in production 2.3% per
year over a ten year--
20 year period,
21 year period is very,
very good but when your
population grows at nearly the
same rate you end up with a very
tiny improvement in standard of
living.
Housing space increased by half
a billion square meters,
on the home building,
a poor, small home,
but something,
a half a billion square meters;
a meter is like a square yard.
Because--but the per capita
because the population grew,
the per capita housing was down
from 4.5 square meters to 3.6
meters per capita.
Three meters is like 9 x 9 and
that was what the per capita
housing;
down in this period of an
improving economy.
The arable land fell from a
quarter of an acre in 1949--from
half an acre in 1949 to a
quarter of an acre in 1983 and
it's gone down since then.
Also, the government,
from the census,
realized how young the
population was and a young
population means,
what's going to happen?
Student:  Speed.
Prof: Momentum.
There's so many more young
people coming into reproductive
age than ones leaving it,
that you're going to have a lot
more child bearers and they
realized this.
From the 1982 census,
another census they took,
the population period was 45
million women in their 40s
leaving reproductive age,
60 million, 1/3 bigger in their
30s,
80 million in their 20s,
and 125 million women in their
teens.
If the teens are coming--just
starting to come into
reproductive ages that means
basically a tripling of the
number of child bearing women
coming into--
three times as many child
bearing women were coming into
reproductive age as were leaving
reproductive age.
Even though they had achieved
this rather incredible fertility
decline,
they realized that,
because of the momentum,
their population would keep
growing for decades yet and they
were really worried about it.
At that time the TFR was
something 2.5 when they were
deciding what to do with it.
If you have--at this age
distribution at this time 2.5
children per women and if three
times as many women are going to
enter reproductive age,
what do you have to do to keep
this down?
You have to go--it's
mathematical--
you have to have 1/3.-- When
you have three times as many
women you have to have 1/3 the
number of births they were
having here.
Three times as many women to
keep the number of children the
same, and you don't reduce the
number of babies,
you have to reduce fertility by
1/3.
So 2.5 divided by 3 is 0.8.
So, the demographics of their
current fertility,
a low fertility,
rate--2.5, their current low
fertility rate but the tripling
of women coming into
reproductive ages,
the mathematics tells you,
you have to set--
you have to somehow get your
fertility rate down to 0.8.
They decided that was going to
be very difficult and they
instituted the one-child policy
at that time.
At the lowest their birth rate
had ever been in,
probably forever,
in Chinese history was exactly
the time that they introduced
the one-child policy.
Years after implementation
there were--
in 1986 which was six years,
seven years after
implementation,
there's still a million more
births than there were the year
earlier,
the number of births kept
rising.
The policy was not a success in
the extreme sense that the
Chinese government wanted it to
be.
They wanted to keep the
year--in the year 2000 they
wanted to keep their population
under 1.2 billion.
When they started this they
were approaching--
they were like 800 billion and
they were desperately hoping to
keep it under 1.2 billion and
they didn't do it,
it was 1.3 billion.
On paper the policy was quite
Draconian.
In the 1982/1983 regulations
included each village would get
a quota for the number of births
that year and the village
leaders would have to ration
this out on the basis of a
waiting list.
Of course only couples with no
prior children could get on the
list.
They had a mandatory IUD
insertion for women who already
had one child and if a woman had
an unauthorized pregnancy an
abortion was supposed to be
mandatory,
and you heard the story about
that.
Although, you should note,
that again,
it wasn't the government--the
abortion that Qing told you
about had nothing to do--
in one sense had nothing
immediately to do with the
government.
She did the abortion way before
anybody knew about it,
her co-workers didn't know
about it,
her workplace didn't know about
it,
government officials didn't
know about it,
it was the suasion,
it was the effect from other
people,
it was these village--these
committees that would keep
visiting you and keep bugging
you that caused her to say,
'okay I'm going to avoid all
this pain and just have the
abortion right away,' so in a
sense the government didn't have
to do anything about it.
With respect to abortion,
the statistics are very
interesting in China.
Sometime, a little after this,
unmarried sexuality started
happening;
in traditional China that--at
least officially -- just plain
didn't happen.
But, as the country modernizes,
one of the things you get into
is unmarried sexuality.
Girls were getting pregnant in
an unmarried state and this was
an unthinkable sort of thing.
What happened to those girls
that were pregnant and
unmarried?
Their parents forced them to
have an abortion.
Some statistics show that the
number of abortions,
which parents required of their
daughters,
their unmarried pregnant
daughters to have,
exceeded the number of
abortions forced under the
one-child policy,
because the one-child policy
also pushed contraceptives,
so actually--and contraceptives
were decent,
so the number of abortions
while high,
was not off the map.
The one-child policy proceeded
and there were--there's
absolutely no doubt about it,
major human rights violations.
You heard about one story,
forced sterilizations,
forced abortions,
these absolutely happened and
this was,
as you heard especially true of
people who had government jobs
or worked in government owned
factories and that was a big
fraction of the economy.
Remember this was a socialist
state, and abortion was supposed
to be mandatory,
and sterilization even,
for any couple that had two or
more children.
Student:  Did they have
orphanages at the time?
Prof: Did they have?
Student:  Orphanages or
was everything increasing the
number of children dropped off
at these orphanages or--
Prof: To adopted out
children.
Student:  Right.
I mean just because--I mean a
lot of people weren't supposed
to have more than one child,
so did people who didn't go
through with an abortion,
and they were able to manage to
have another child did they drop
their kid off at an orphanage?
Prof: Yes I haven't--
yes I haven't seen good
statistics about that and I
don't know if the Chinese
government lets out good
statistics on that.
A huge number of girls,
almost all girls,
were sent to orphanages and
because of the poverty of the
orphanages,
I mean it was lot of rural
orphanages that didn't have much
money to begin with,
they basically couldn't take
care of the babies,
huge death rate,
huge maltreatment rate.
This is when Americans started
adopting Chinese babies kind of
en mass and many Americans went
over to pick up the baby and the
stories that came back about
children just tied into the
cribs,
emaciated, sores over the body
and really in very,
very bad situations.
Yes, indeed,
as far as we can tell but I
don't have good statistics,
yes a big surge in daughters
given--girl babies given up to
orphanages.
Okay so in this--I guess it's
time to finish.
We'll just have to continue
this next time,
cutting into our next lecture.